freiberg sachsen gestern abend rund 1000
gegner protestieren gegen die korona
maßnahmen der alten und der neuen
bundesregierung
[Applaus]
ab jetzt muss ich auf die straße
demonstrieren es scheint ihr niemand
verbieten so etwas eigentlich treten auf
seine überzeugung sage ich lasst mich
zum beispiel dürfen also dass in
ebeleben also da wird auch keiner
maßnahme irgendwie greifen im
verweigerer gibt es in sachsen besonders
viele nur 58,5 prozent der einwohner
sind zweifach gegen korona geimpft so
wenig wie nirgends sonst in deutschland
dabei war die akzeptanz ist sich in den
vergangenen jahren impfen zu lassen in
sachsen wie in ganz ostdeutschland lange
viel größer als im westen erst mit der
korona pandemie kippte das was hängt
meiner wahrnehmung nach damit zusammen
dass das impfen immer auch ein test für
das vertrauen in staatliche einrichtung
ist das heißt weil die unzufriedenheit
in teilen ostdeutschlands sehr hoch ist
weil damit stimmung gemacht wird gegen
die merkel diktatur gegen die da oben
deshalb steht jetzt das impfen sozusagen
auch im fadenkreuz und wird dann
entsprechend stärker abgelehnt als in
den meisten teilen westdeutschlands
in sachsen ist die sieben tage incidents
mit 1082 am höchsten in deutschland
hier in colditz auf halbem wege zwischen
leipzig und dresden liegt die inzidenz
sogar bei
bürger meister robert tillmann hat wegen
corona große sorgen mitarbeiter in der
verwaltung fallen aus kommunale
bauprojekte müssen gestoppt werden
intensiv patienten ausgeflogen werden
deshalb hat will man keine bedenken
gegen eine corona impfpflicht
ich glaube dass ein großer fehler
gewesen von der politik in 2020 dass man
das von anfang an ausgeschlossen hat es
muss immer diese option noch geben und
ich glaube wir werden bleibt man nicht
vorbeikommen wenn es der staat sich
nicht ändern hat bei den bürgern von
colditz gehen die meinungen beim thema
corona impfpflicht auseinander ich finde
es nicht in ordnung dass er jeder für
sich selbst entscheiden aber impfen geht
ob er nicht enthüllt aber oft teuren
seite gibt es eine richtige frau die von
einem da nicht geimpft das hilft die
anderen ausgeben sommer zu machen
mindestens zu 51 prozent wäre für eine
verpflichtung allgemeine impfpflicht
wäre insofern gut da müssten manche gar
nicht über darüber nachdenken ob sie
sich impfen lassen das wird es manchen
erleichtern unterstützung für die
impfpflicht kommt aus der wissenschaft
professor cornelia betsch analysiert die
impfbereitschaft und die motive
ungeimpfte vergangenen freitag wurde
ihrer neuesten studie veröffentlicht
sie sehen dass in den stark betroffenen
bundesländern also die schon anfangen
patienten auszufliegen in andere
bundesländer dass sich da die im
freundschaft nicht verändert und das
gerade um die ängste die panini immer
noch sehr sehr anders wahrnehmen
tatsächlich glaube ich das ist ein guter
zeitpunkt ist über die impfpflicht
nachzudenken der künftige bundeskanzler
sieht das auch so und verkündet
vergangenen donnerstag
dass wir eine offene abstimmung im
bundestag haben werden über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht der anschlusses
gegeben da glaube ich wird es jetzt auch
vorangehen und aus meiner sicht sollte
es auch zu anderen solchen entscheidung
des bundestages kommen ich bin auch
ziemlich sicher dass das der fall sein
wird
und auch die koalitionspartner ziehen
mit
mit großem respekt für unterschiedliche
abwägungen stellen wir uns einer debatte
bei der verantwortung für dieses land
tragen die vorbereitungen für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht müssen getroffen
werden ab märz kommenden jahres könnte
die allgemeine krone impfpflicht kommen
dabei hatten politiker der späteren
ampelkoalition genau das immer wieder
ausgeschlossen es wäre falsch wenn jetzt
eine debatte beginnt über
pflichten und ähnliches die morgen
eingeführte impfpflicht löst für
übermorgen sagt null probleme ich bin
gegen die impfpflicht die fdp hat im
wahlkampf
freiheitsbeschränkungen durch corona
häufig kritisiert nun muss sie den
wortbruch erklären dass die impfpflicht
doch kommt ich war dagegen weil es für
liberale schwierig ist mit pflichten zu
agieren aber wir hatten eine völlig
andere ausgangssituation wir haben jetzt
pandemische zahlen instanzen die
besorgnis erregend sind und die
situation ist dramatisch deswegen müssen
wir in der regierung auch andere
antworten finden das ist für liberale
nicht einfach aber wir stehen in
verantwortung und freiheit bedeutet eben
auch sich darum zu kümmern dass andere
die geimpft sind sich frei bewegen
können doch nicht jeder liberale sieht
das so wolfgang kubicki bundestags
vizepräsident von der fdp ist nach wie
vor gegen eine impfpflicht für ihn sei
das grundrecht auf körperliche
unversehrtheit verletzt
greifen wir nun in dieses prinzip
pauschal ein muss dies verfassungsfest
erklärt werden
dabei hatten die wissenschaftlichen
dienste des bundestages schon 2016 die
verfassungsrechtliche zulässigkeit einer
impfpflicht festgestellt
ein solcher eingriff im solchen fall
wäre verhältnismäßig sofern damit
legitime ziele verfolgt werden und der
ferner geeignet erforderlich und
angemessen ist
[Musik]
andere länder sind weiter als
deutschland für personal im gesundheits
und pflegebereich gilt die impfpflicht
bereits in lettland belgien frankreich
slowenien italien und in griechenland
hier gilt außerdem die impfpflicht für
alle über 60-jährigen und österreich
führt ab februar kommenden jahres die
korona impfpflicht für alle erwachsenen
ein
selbst wenn die impfpflicht in
deutschland eingeführt wird kommt sie
für die vierte welle viel zu spät aber
sie ist den gesamten situation in der
wir uns befinden die impfpflicht zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt jetzt heute noch in
diesem jahr wenig bringen wenig bringen
weil bisher nicht umgesetzt
wird diese wirkung sich erst im nächsten
jahr entfalten
intensiv und notfallmedizin
sprechen sich für eine impfpflicht
aussehen aber ein risiko
[Musik]
das wir im ganzen jahr jetzt über eine
zunehmende polarisierung dieser position
erleben und das wäre sicherlich eine
große gruppe haben die unentschlossenen
erst die sich aber jetzt unter der
androhung der impfpflicht und tom
stellen sogar dann immer mehr in die
seite der impfwilligen der imb skeptiker
schlägt und wir tatsächlich jetzt so
einen richtigen auseinanderdriften
gesellschaft haben
[Applaus]
die impfgegner einen freiberg gestern
abend sind zwar laut aber sie sind eine
minderheit sich mit ihr
auseinanderzusetzen davor scheuten sich
die politisch verantwortlichen
ihnen fehlte der mut von anfang an auch
über eine corona impfpflicht zu sprechen